we're continuing to learn more and more
about how significantly taxes would go
up for a lot of people under the Trump
Republican tax plan and last week I told
you that the Trump tax plan would raise
taxes on families earning under seventy
five thousand dollars a year it would
raise taxes significantly on graduate
students and then at the beginning of
this week I told you about how the
Republican tax plan would actually raise
taxes on more than half of Americans in
the long run now to be clear I'm not
against taxes going up or down just in
principle or in the abstract right but I
do believe that if you're campaigning on
tax decreases you shouldn't be raising
taxes for more than half of all
Americans and that if you're going to
raise taxes you should really be raising
the taxes on the ultra-rich who have a
bigger and bigger share of the total
country's wealth as as time has gone on
particularly because taxing them is much
better for the economy than increasing
taxes on middle-income people okay we
now have a new report which focuses on
seniors it has been done by the AARP and
it says that one out of five seniors
about 6.3 million will either see no
change to their taxes or an increase in
taxation in 2019 1.2 million of them
would get a tax increase but remember
this thing about how this tax plan
contains temporary and permanent
provisions and that once the temporary
provisions expire taxes are going to go
up for more than half of all Americans
once you look at the number of seniors
that will see a tax hike once those
temporary provisions phase-out over five
million seniors will be seeing tax
increases as a result of this bill but
the seniors and I'm talking about not
the old for wealthy ones that are in
Donald Trump's cabinet just regular old
folks right they're actually going to
get screwed twice by the bill because
not only will they see a tax hike in the
long term they will also be on the
receiving end of Medicare cuts and cuts
to other senior services as a result of
this tax bill and I was thinking back as
I read the report to all those terms
that Donald Trump likes to use about his
harebrained ideas he calls them it's a
beautiful plan it's an elegant idea this
is the furthest thing from it right
seniors will get screwed families
earning under seventy five grand a year
will get screwed grad students will get
ultra screwed it's almost like the
incredible overwhelming lion's share of
the benefits go to the people who were
already really rich the ultra rich the
obscenely rich and Donald Trump's own
family himself which of course he says
this wouldn't be good for him but it
would be great for him just seems like
it's such a politically risky move
though because the elderly votes I mean
it's not as if you're targeting young
people or just grad students who aren't
gonna vote for Trump anyway yeah but are
these older people gonna turn around and
vote for the Democrat maybe not maybe
not and that's why I think it's
interesting that the AARP is getting
involved because the AARP on the one
hand it's a very powerful organization a
lobby
for seniors but on the other hand
there's been so much anti AARP
propaganda spreading around right-wing
media lately that who knows what effect
it will actually have and there's a
rumor a discussion that moderate Senate
Republicans like Lisa Murkowski she is
in principle opposed to what would be
the impact of this bill based on
everything we know but what I read Pat
is that she's thinking of voting for it
in the Senate then it will go to
reconsider conciliation and she'll
eventually vote against that compromise
bill and she'll be able to say listen
I'm not against tax reform I voted for
the Senate version but once we
conferenced with the house build those
House Republicans are not like us I
can't in good faith support it which is
a way to kind of ride the fence and get
the benefits from every aspect of this
yeah I could see some centrist Democrats
flipping on this too oh you think so
perhaps I really I hope not that would
be absolutely pathetic so anyway that's
what's going on tax hikes all around
everybody take one unless you're really
really rich the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad